here you go you seen the thre yeah
yeah what' you think when you first saw
it when I first saw the book you know
you know like anybody who thinks more of
themsel they they they want to know why
am I not on the cover however when I
look at some of the characters in here I
know why I'm not on the cover you know
it's really interesting and uh why I say
it is because it humbles you you become
humbled when you look at the people on
here and I don't know if they're all
still alive a lot of them are dead yeah
so uh I don't have to be on the cover of
Life I just want to know that I've I
just Mark I just want to know that I
survived and here I find I found myself
on the on the uh so that would be the
back right you're on the back cover back
right cover so and then of course I
wanted to know if these guys all
outperformed me on video on no no no no
this this is just random this is all
just random yeah and there's a lot of
people that are not even in the book
they're on the cover yeah yeah so yeah
they're just just portraits I like well
you know what you're you're an artist
and you uh you're art through picture
picture taking you know I couldn't
believe how good good-looking you made
me in this
picture well I mean I mean you're I've
said this many times to you and and
think I think I've done it in some
interviews where I've said people that
Mike Dow's interview on my channel is is
the is the Pinnacle of what I'm trying
to do right because when you came when
you first came in I you know we were
talking on the phone and I recognized
this guy he's a he knows how to tell a
story yeah and I had this idea that I I
would rather not speak at all if
possible in these interviews the less I
speak the better always right and uh if
I didn't say a single word I think it
would be perfect so I asked you I could
you tell this whole story you know talk
about where you're from how you grew up
right how you got into the police force
how how it all developed and how this
story unfolded and then and every once
in a while just touch on the
psychological like
what you what was going through your
head while you're doing it and you
nailed it on the head so perfectly and
i' I've never seen anybody do that as
well as you but I've had I've had some
magnificent stories told yeah and some
of these stories are incredible and here
and when I compare my life to the
journeys that many of these people have
I'm I'm I feel spared because as you
just said many of these people aren't
alive today but here I am holding a book
in your office that I'm on the back
cover of not the front but my life has
been a journey and this is part of it
and it really is it's warming to know
that of I I assume you've interviewed
thousands of people 8,000 now 8,000
people I hey not so bad for 8,000 people
you know you know I qualify and um and
first you know Mark first when I did
this my son one of my sons my other son
not this one that's in the studio with
you today he was Dad why did you go on
that show we're trying to do a movie and
a book and all this other stuff he goes
you're going to honish reputation I said
to my son I said listen it's cathartic
it's it's a way for me to to to become a
Target in some ways but in the other way
I'm able to to give a free lesson and I
I think I told you on one of our
speaking engagements that um I I think I
should have been a
teacher and uh in some ways that I
missed that Mark but Mark but in some
ways I'm happy now that um coming on
here and been able to share in this
story my story
um it brought me to the fact and many of
you people have said it that love is
what we really need in this life and
this book shows a lot of love because
the energy and effort that you and the
people that that come in here and
sacrifice their own inner GS and loins
to make these books of success not this
book but the the show of success and
it's really a wonderful experience and
and it opens doors to people they change
their lives uh people that judge them uh
in in a negative way
actually get feel the heart of people
that speak in here we're all people yeah
and people actually rally around them
and hope and and and hope for the better
for a lot of people that come in here
and sacrifice but this book's been
really wonderful for me because my it's
now on my uh coffee table at home and
you can't miss it so it people might use
it as a paper we but that's fine you're
going to see it and I really appreciate
it m thank you much you're I'm so glad
you were a part of this project yeah
thank you you you you've set the bar for
what I'm looking to do thank you well
you know what I was actually un unsure
that I could accomplish accomplish that
but when I played it back which I did I
was I was impressed with myself cuz I I
didn't know that I could actually carry
something well it was a perfect mix of a
of a great story yeah an amazing story
right and then you you you talk about
how you felt the psychological things
that were going on through your head but
then you added like a little bit comedy
and your your presentation is is so just
riveting and it's like it's just what I
always look for well I found something
humor and love those are the two things
that make us work and uh thanks for
making me a part of the book and and and
a part of the S underbelly I'll be
forever you will thank you mate thank
you